[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i
wear makeup not because i feel like i
need it
to be pretty or whatever i just
i use it because i like to see what i
can do
with the hands
i just think it's a lot of fun just to
experiment with
[Music]
freedom to be creative and see what i
can do
when i went out and about before these
hands and i was just walking around with
my arms people would always
stare at them they would come over to me
and ask
what happened and i had to repeat the
same story like
i got a really bad disease called
meningitis septicemia
nearly died and it's just a really
negative topical conversation whereas
now
with these hands when i go outside
everyone who sees us are excited by them
feel free to play with our hands maureen
that's great that really is it's
fabulous
it's more like whoa how did you get
these hands how do i get some they're
amazing like you're like a superhero
you can give thumbs up as well yeah
everyone's really excited by them rather
than feeling sorry for me all the time
and i like that so much better
[Applause]
there are muscle sensors inside of the
hands
so you can actually control them just by
touching them
the senses are connected to my muscles
i squeeze my muscles to close the hand
i flex to open and then if i want to
change the grip then i can flex again
they definitely helped me to multitask
so i am now able to like
pull a suitcase and hold the hot
chocolate and drink it
that look i've been practicing with the
hands
and i can do a fist
very nice and then having these hands
you have
the freedom to have your independence
like you can do what you want without
having to rely on other people
like i've got a finger shadow
i really hope that these hands will be
available on national health service
these hands are ten thousand pounds a
pair i believe
and that's a lot cheaper than what we
used to have
you know what it's so heartwarming just
watching it
like doing that this is what i mean the
simple things
that change your life simple stuff like
holding a hand or telling her she's got
a little finger shadow it's like
it's so cute
yep yep i feel like my determination has
got me to
where i am today impressive
the main goal is like ultimate
independence just like
anybody else with hands can have because
obviously i don't want to live with you
forever no offense
and but i want to like move out and have
my own house and i want to be able to do
everything that anyone with hands can do
so that's the main goal in the long run
and i think we're definitely
nothing far away from that
i think it'll make everyone not just
like amputees feel better
everyone just stop judging each other
and just live
your life without being judged
you